il n'y a pas de plus grand fléau qui
ravage les états unis de l'intérieur le
président lui-même prend la crise des
opioïdes très au sérieux
leur jeune a été arrêté à la frontière
qui leur passeur
pour ça il a travaillé sous couverture
pendant un an c'est peut-être dangereux
de pousser une vente là ouais mais je
vois pas quel au choix
notre produit sera le véritable tout
premier anti douleur non addictives
succès ils ont associé à la diction
s'allument dans leur cerveau et
aujourd'hui elle même
je cherche mon garçon étiez vous au
courant de quelques problèmes avec votre
fils comme quoi
sont appuyés en sortait résultat tu veux
que leur médicament d'un milliard de
dollars qu'ils soient retirés du marché
ça pourrait coûter beaucoup plus que ton
travail de prof faut que tu ailles blanc
plein pour dire la vérité
fais attention
est ce que ceux ci drik et le genre à
des volets dit non parce que ce serait
déplaisant pour tout le monde
[Musique]
ils vont vous attaquer mais ce que vous
faites là pour être la chose la plus
importante de votre vie
office de transporter la drogue pour toi
depuis le tabac c'est la plus grosse
crise de santé publique ok ce n'est pas
notre responsabilité celle de qui
tu peux pas aller là-bas tout seul on
peut pas lâcher
vous croyez qu'on est là pour faire quoi
faire une différence
on peut tu as pourri n'importe où dans
le monde
on n'a plus beaucoup de temps dernière
chance